this is monster reunion well nothing
happened there yeah no no light one um
yeah nose was really good
I I kind of like when they go back to a
character that like almost completely
forgot about while you're like
centipeetle like oh yeah that's right
like that whole we look creature thing
and I like sir seen her like you know
almost human but not quite and I look at
the south centipede oh by the way in
human form still just as creepy girl I
love the sounds I love boats they were
it's like that evil head from evil again
um so yeah it comes across I finds out
he can get his healing power back again
tries on centipeetle
uh works pretty well but it's still not
great so they try to he tries to
communicate with her and gives us whole
story how she was like captive crew came
down and then the war happened but
something made them retreat and there
was a big light what was the big night
what was in deemed and the three die
maids retreat what scares a Jim diamonds
um I'm assuming that's what that was and
then like goes to UM he takes her to the
ship she's reunite with a crew that all
kind of look like her they're also
centipeetle thingies and they can't
leave them there they seem happy
liked a like how she tries to hit the
handprint thing and then it turns into
the cockroach and I was just like all
that's accident my fear is you were just
like so hard but just oh that sucks and
I'm just thinking why can't Steven just
inspire yeah I did yeah I thought I was
like handled the crew or something like
that and no and you just like looked at
me and say well good for him
sister-sister flag out it got it
um so uh yeah I say the one thing I
didn't maybe I just missed it reso you
teach me how to say something in gem
like you know hi hello and always look
at the diamonds like Sam what happened
to her and stuff like I'm sorry this
happened to you that's what that was
referring
- right wait so cuz Leslie said teach me
how to say I'm sorry
oh that was my assumption uh but I'm not
entirely sure so um yeah no I thought
this was really good I like episodes
where people have to communicate through
something very simple I thought it was a
sweet ending locking your friend up in a
ship that will be their tomb for the
rest of eternity or their bubble sounds
nicer um I'm going to prison
I mean bubble bubble prison um so no I
like it I I like I said any kind of
episode particularly with Steve and it
feels like where he can really
communicate sort of one-on-one with
somebody uh I guess if I kind of a
different way and I like the crayon
drawings I like the very simple drawings
that show these horrific events that
happen you know I like just this very
even girl I like just showing all the
crew and then just putting a line
through them I mean that just you know
what that means and it's heartbreaking
but it's also crayons you know so I sort
of like they can show it through sort of
this very different simple way um I
didn't need the cran sex ed version of
how the centipedes procreate but apart
from that you didn't see that that was
completely men your interpretation is
very different from my interpretation um
so uh just so many legs is assassin so
many everything that was when they went
back to like pure centipede forb I'm
just like yeah creepy science enemies I
love the eye in the mouth and all those
little moving legs sound yeah I'm just a
clue I don't mind like in whatever
movies and shows and games and stuff in
real life I'm like oh that thing um
I'm more creeped up by centipedes and
I'm of like spiders yeah me too I'm
actually not that creepy I mean there
are rules if the spiders bigger than a
quarter it goes outside
um but yeah there's I'm designated
spider murderer in my house
yeah um it's topless yeah you know you
can get just one
sighs am i freakin fist then I'll be
like okay I'm gonna get the shotgun but
well what are the ones that like you
know if I can kill you as a black widow
that it can kill you or yeah but how
many black ya know in America uh Ellie's
idolaters the brown recluse which gets
misattributed to so many like dangerous
spider bites and people freak up about
the brown recluse and it's like it's not
even really that much of a thing up here
and it did you know the one thing I'm
realizing mosquitos they are my best
friend whatever beautiful um you heard
me right spiders in my best friend
should tell you why I should tell you
what my personality's like um the one
thing I'm realizing with this show is
that you know you think like you know
they start we are the crystal gems
garnet amethyst and pearl and Steven oh
four characters maybe some side
characters I feel like the cast has
grown so much that it kind of feels
strange where it's you know it's like
wait where's lion centipede oh yeah it's
like where's lion where's peridot
where's uh lapis and stuff like that
like you know it's kind of weird we
don't see them around and I do sort of
question like um where are they they're
sort of just somewhere else - Oh fair
it's really only those three there's
nobody else I'm really like where they
like I was gonna ask you were sent to me
oh no oh I actually just thought uh in
the couple episodes ago I'm like oh like
the dad lives in the van I didn't know
that I totally didn't know oh I always
figured that I mean I never saw where I
live but I was just like yeah this is
weird
he lives in his van um really I read did
you lose the money by really that's
weird like yeah that's a lien of one of
the only normal things that's fine you
know but living in the van that's odd
yeah that's the only thing that makes
sense to me is him living it I was like
I could see that that's not like you
live in the car wash or something like
that um you know that's his shower you
don't want a shower so like a living a
man um but uh yeah trying to think
everything's pretty self-explanatory I
mean it is good um but
I can't think of like too much else
that's like you know we can really what
that scared them off let's get just some
sort of bright light mmm
lots of mm right lights and good things
I guess but mostly bad things um yeah um
the eye looks like a pokeball that's
weird
hmm it's Pikachu he's the bright
light of course hmm